is there an ultimate purpose of life
yeah sure what is it
what we're doing here which is what
hopefully trying to make peace
is that enough
we'll see yeah because if it's better
than the alternative what's the
alternative hell
okay which we're toying with I don't
mean us well us too that's for sure but
you know things are things are shaky at
the moment on many fronts and we have
this opportunity in front of us all of
us
to have a very abundant world right
where everyone has enough
and maybe more than enough and we're
we're shaky about that we're not sure
that that's acceptable and we're not
sure everybody should have it we're not
sure everybody deserves it and even
ourselves and
and we're retreating into our Corners in
some real sense and we're not addressing
the elephants under the carpet and you
can't do that like the things we're
discussing contentiously now you know
they make for rough conversations but
they make for a lot rougher streets if
you don't talk them out and you have to
do that a spirit of ignorance
[Music]
thank you
so our first special guest is Dr Jordan
B Peterson he is a clinical psychologist
and professor emeritus at the University
of Toronto from 1993 to 1998 he served
as an assistant and then associate
professor of psychology at Harvard she
spent 15 years writing maps of meaning
the architecture of belief Dr Peterson
has penned the popular Global
bestsellers Beyond order 12 more rules
for life and 12 rules for life and
antidote to chaos in 2016 before the
publication of 12 rules several of Dr
Peterson's online lectures videos and
interviews went viral launching him into
unprecedented International prominence
as a public intellectual and educator
with his colleagues Dr Peterson has
pronounced two on has produced two
online programs to help people
understand themselves better and to
improve the psychological and practical
functioning he's currently working on
online university dubbed Peterson
Academy
please welcome Dr Peterson
we also have with us
Jonathan pojo he is an artist and he
studies Christian symbolism and he also
studies post modernism right God forbid
for some right so we also have with us
our beloved Muhammad hijab he is an
author comparative religionist and
philosopher of religion he's the
co-founder of our Institute sapience
Institute and is a researcher and
instructor instructor for the
organization he has a ba in politics and
a master's degree in history and he also
acquired a second master's degree in
Islamic Studies from the school over
here into an African studies and he
completed a third master's degree in
applied theology from the University of
Oxford and now he's studying his PhD on
the philosophy of religion specifically
on the contingency argument for God's
existence in addition hijab has
undergone formal training in Islamic
Studies with a focus on the Quran
prophetic traditions and legal reasoning
hijab has completed Islamic Seminary
courses and has been given formal
permission to relay Islamic knowledge on
selected Islamic Fields Muhammad is one
of the very few Muslim public figures
who deal comparatively with political
philosophical and Theological issues
such as and has amassed a following on
with many subscribers on YouTube in
English and Arabic so please welcome
Muhammad hijab and of course Jonathan
foreign
so because I'm 100 disagreeable and not
polite at all
um
I want to just I want to get the
elephant out of the room
I do like to to do that and um there's
been a recent video that you put up a
message to the Muslims and before I say
this I do want to speak about the
important topics the theological topics
and all these kind of postmodernism like
that that will come but I just wanted to
mention this first because I for me it's
just get the elephant out of the room
that we can move on
um sometimes it's just replaced by a
slightly smaller elephant
well a smaller elephant is better than
nothing yeah
um I was going to say is that you know
it didn't land well with a lot of the
Muslim Community yeah and I think the
reason why is that it was seen as a
condescending it was seen as
um kind of patronizing that what was
your intention of this video exactly
to start a dialogue stupidly and badly
[Music]
because that's how you have to start
you know we talked already about the
idea of Tolerance and I'm actually not
here
to be tolerant you know because
tolerance sort of presumes that I know
what I'm doing and you guys don't but
I'll put up with you anyways and uh
see I don't actually think I know what
I'm doing exactly and so I think while
you might have something to teach me and
so it's not so much tolerance as
I would say hopefully something
approximating an expression of
reasonable humility which is
well first of all we
we occupy the same space And as far as
I'm concerned it'd be better if we got
along and we've all had our own
Revelations you know personally and
and let's say socially and we don't know
how to integrate those Revelations and
that's rough that's hard
um
and so I'm here to listen and
the message was
Preposterous in some sense
although not much more so than the
message I made to Christians which I
wouldn't say say was exactly
flattering
and uh you know I thought it would
probably ruffle some feathers but
but I thought it might also initiate a
dialogue or at least further it and that
has happened you know I mean certainly
there were many people who were
irritated at me and thought that I was
being condescending and I wasn't trying
to be because I I do have a lot of
people who are paying attention to my
lectures of course around the world on
the Islamic side which is quite
surprising to me especially with regard
to the attention that's been given to
the biblical lectures and I don't take
any of that for granted and I wasn't
trying to either capitalize on it or or
uh interfere with it I was trying to do
the next stupid thing that might move
things forward a bit and that's actually
it's actually worked I would say well
first of all I am here and I know that's
not a direct consequence of that message
but at least it didn't break it and
there have been many other
Muslim groups who've reached out to me
in a serious way at least in part
because of that and so I think we have
to understand that
we're going to stumble into each other a
fair bit if we actually try to talk
because of all the elephants and the
snakes that are lurking under the carpet
and I think it's a very good thing to
get the mountain open yeah I I'm a very
agreeable person as it turns out yes I
know it's to my to my detriment but um I
also know I wouldn't have guessed to be
honest that you're very agreeable yes
it's it's one of my major character
flaws but um I don't like Conflict at
all and but the reason I I would say I'm
prone to engage in it is because
sometimes
what's under the carpet needs to be
revealed because it's going to cause a
lot of trouble if it just sits there and
Brews or Broods and multiplies and so
here's one of the advantages of
disagreeable people having them around
because they will haul things up for
inspection that everyone else might
be loath to confront you know the
downside is well you might do that too
often you know and that's a hard thing
to get right so I'm not here in a spirit
of Tolerance I'm here in the spirit of
ignorance and I'm hoping see the other
thing I've been thinking through and
yeah guys can
tell me what you think about this is
it seems that in the situation we're in
now
sort of globally speaking that
it would be useful for people of
religious faith
to note that there are other people of
religious Faith with whom they have much
in common one of them being religious
faith and that they are also confronting
as people of religious Faith a world
that is attempting to let's say shake
itself free of that and so it isn't
exactly obvious to me that it's a great
time for people of religious Faith to
concentrate on their differences given
that there are perhaps more important
elephants to address let's say or fish
to fry and so I've been trying to I'm
very ignorant about the Islamic
tradition and I'm trying to rectify that
it's very difficult to step outside your
own culture and to really understand
someone else's and so and I'm under no
Illusions I hope about the degree of
understanding that I've managed but I
have tried to understand what we might
share in common
and that's crucial and so certainly one
of the
ideas that we all share in common on the
religious front let's say is that there
is an ultimate unity that should be
placed Above All Else and so that's part
of the Great monotheistic tradition and
I'm going to speak mostly as a
psychologist rather than as say an
advocate of the Christian tradition
because I it isn't obvious to me that I
let me kind of push back a little bit at
that point because you're an individual
like obviously in your newest book
you're talking about
um category about precision and I would
say you're an individual that is very
precise they're categorized like if I
was to say anything I would say that you
all individuals are scrupulously
meticulous and exactitude and I don't
know meticulousness or whatever yeah so
you speak and you think about what
you're going to say before you say it
that's what you're known for in fact if
someone says something which is uh kind
of off the market ill but you pull them
up for it right and you know usually
because I don't understand it then you
know for example like the Kathy Newman
interview like the assumptions and the
questioning that she had she had when
she was questioning yourself you pulled
her up on it and that's why it became so
uh popular the discussion was so popular
and just a clinical psychologist so what
I was going to say is this for example
if I were to make a video right I say
this message to the you know to White
Canadians or something yeah yeah and I
said you know it's hard to talk to them
and I say look you know um sensitively
when I you reach out to some Russians
you know oh you know heaven forbid you
know reach out to Black Africans or
First Nation people you know whatever it
may be
how do you think
the community of why Canadians let's say
for sake of argument will react to that
kind of message well if it was you yeah
well you're pretty disagreeable so you'd
probably get bit back a lot yeah but
exactly I don't I don't it's hard to say
until you do it you know yeah I mean I
have reached out to other communities
let's say I did an interview with a
friend of mine who's a Native American
Carver who lives on the west coast and
you know I'm not very happy with the
narrative that's being promoted in
Canada which is that the European
settlement of Canada is best viewed as
genocidally Colonial and having said
that my friend this Carver was in a
residential school in Canada and the
residential schools were put forward by
the government in an attempt and other
institutions in an attempt to separate
the indigenous children from their
families and then socialize them rapidly
according to European norms and there
was some positive
motivation for that and sometimes that
helped and worked but it wasn't the
things that did happen was that some
schools were let's say invaded by people
of a pronounced pedophilic and and
sadistic bent and my friend ended up in
one of those schools and his life was so
Dreadful that you can't even hear about
it without
without
without serious emotional damage and so
you know I went forward without
discussion and it was very contentious
but it went very well and it it told a
story that was true and needed to be
told yeah and so you know you step into
foreign territory at your peril that's
for sure but
you know and it was relatively difficult
for me to arrange
for this to be a possibility of course
and and but my my thought again because
I'm trying to look for what we have to
offer each other rather than what
divides us I thought it was worthwhile
and an economy as volatile as this one
it's important to have control when
you're making a big purchase like a new
car that's where cars in comes into play
carzing is completely changing the way
you buy a car online an online car
shopping website with millions of listed
Vehicles karzing works with over 25 000
dealers Nationwide to help you find your
dream car by partnering with Credit
Agencies lenders and dealerships carzing
provides you with everything you need
before stepping your foot into a
dealership their mission is to make auto
financing quick and easy while providing
a modern hassle-free way of shopping for
cars their Innovative technology and
financial tools provide consumers with
the ability to instantly pre-qualify
online without affecting your credit
score plus you can search for vehicles
with instant financing details including
down payment monthly payment term and
APR once you find your dream car at your
ideal budget all you have to do is bring
your save deal voucher with you to the
dealership to finalize your next ride
carzing offers transparency to the max
you know your purchasing options before
you set foot into the dealership which
makes the whole process so much more
convenient visit karzing.com Jordan
today to skip the guesswork and find the
best deals near you that's carzing.com
Jordan
push back again once again once again on
this point so for example it's not
always what you say sometimes it can be
what you don't say so for instance
I think you've become somewhat of an
emblem of Western Civilization right in
terms of you're an intention to help us
no you have and I'll also push back on a
point that this is a foreign culture
because I think that it's like you've
mentioned this in lecture as well that
Islam has now become part of like you
know Western culture yeah well that's
the open question as we noted in the
introductory marks it's like well are is
Islam part of the West we're kind of
having the same discussion about Russia
in some real sense and yeah that's
really going well at the moment yeah so
there's that part but what I would say
is that you know if there is a bloody
history of Western colonialism and
that's almost undeniable like for
example look at Algeria for instance
Algeria when it was annexed by France
and there's no dispute there's no
dispute in what happened there so the
issue I'll give you one example of many
this Spanish colonialism of uh Latin
America for example
um there are things that happened and
it's people saying that things that
happened on only just on the Western
Front yeah uh those things that happened
on the Muslim front as well of course
that's true yeah no doubt about it right
no I'm not going to stand here and you
know defend them who came and we're very
intolerant to uh producing Christians
and kick them out of their homes and
stuff like that who existed in Spain as
well in fact so the point is I feel like
I don't know as a psychologist I think
my question would be to you that don't
you think is it of any benefit to be
concessionary in this regard like to
start off a discussion by saying like we
know
um that these are things that could
cause resentment yes because like for
example I know a lot of Algerian people
and this is very clear in their
historical memory yes and the the
accusation will be that the West have
Colonial Amnesia here they don't they
are not taking into account what they've
done I'll be honest with you they don't
even know how well okay yeah well
absolutely I mean look here here's how I
would address that psychologically
um in in many of the mythological
stories that I've read There is the
motif of the evil uncle and so for
example in the ancient Egyptian
cosmology
um that there were two there were four
deities four Central deities although a
host of associated deities and one of
them was Osiris who was the deity of the
state that might be a good way of
thinking about it and he had an evil
brother Seth who was always conspiring
in the background to overthrow the state
and to establish his own rules say based
on Power and the Egyptians this is
thousands of years ago had figured out
by that point because their society was
quite large that
there is something in the social
structure itself that posed a threat to
the structure and that was the tendency
for the structure and its leaders to
become willfully blind and for
conspiratorial
powers or patterns that would use
resentment and the desire for power to
overthrow that they thought of Osiris as
willfully blind and Seth has an eternal
danger and that's true and and then but
there's a there's another element to the
evil Uncle too which is that in some
real sense and it's a very difficult
thing to sort through morally
all of us walk on blood soaked ground
because human history is
in some regards a nightmarish
catastrophe and some of that's just
because life was so difficult but it's
also because people did in unbelievably
cruel and malicious and deceptive
uh committed committed unbelievably
cruel and atrocious and deceptive acts
and so we're all stuck with this problem
that
here we are in relative peace and
Harmony so far although we seem to be
doing everything we can to try to
disrupt that at the moment and part of
the price that's being paid for that is
an endless Litany of historical
catastrophe and then we all have to face
up to what does that mean for us in
terms of our individual responsibility
and how do we construe ourselves and our
society in light of that fact and we
could go back and forth continually
about whose historical atrocities were
worse and that's a rough contest because
you know the devil is definitely in the
details there and then it also brings up
the other problem which is well
when the Spaniards went to Central
America a lot of the Bloodshed they
produced or the death they produced was
actually a consequence of the
introduction of disease because that
took out about 95 percent of the native
population in the Western Hemisphere and
then the conquistadors were well maybe
they weren't the finest representatives
of the of the highest flowering Western
Civilization we don't know what to what
degree they were the sort of thugs that
couldn't get along at home and went out
adventuring and and then and and even if
I say attempted to take full
responsibility for that I'm not sure
what it would mean because I suspect I
have a lot more in common with you
people in the modern world than I do
with Spanish conquistadors from 300
years ago now I'm not saying I bear no
responsibility for the Bloodshed of the
past but I would say we all bear that
responsibility and that's something I
would say that something like the
conception of original sin yeah that's
the point of difference uh be honest I
would disagree that point like as a
Muslim there is a verse no Quran says
that one Soul should not bear the
responsibility of someone else's actions
yeah well that that's the other ethical
complications so can you call me out
yeah in relationships
but it's complicated right because but
because at the same time you do say and
I don't mean you personally but you know
we can say things like Well the West is
not bearing sufficient responsibility
for its Colonial past and so at some
level that kind of devolves down to the
individual so let me let me kind of
rephrase it then I think you know I
think that's more of a left on criticism
that's like you know there's reparations
and affirmative action programs yeah I'm
not advocating any of that and not I
even believe in any of that to be honest
with you nor me yeah so what I was
putting as an alternative to that is
this is there is this kind of I would
call this maybe an oriental it's a new
orientalist narrative which states that
Islam is incapable of XYZ call it
tolerance Call It Whatever It Is and
look at what's happened in Islamic
history you've got all of these deaths
and you've got all of these kinds of
things are happening comparative to what
we have in the west and what we're
saying is that let's look at what you
have in the west because liberalism was
an ideology that was cited in the 17th
century like I mean really it was
crystallized you know with John Locke
and all those kind of things then and
after liberalism was established in fact
the Constitution and the documents for
the founding fathers and stuff like that
were based on the liberal secular
principles even after that you had
Napoleonic Wars even after that you had
colonialism continue you had slavery
continue until 1867 whatever was you
know the American Civil War ended
um so what we're saying is that this
picture of history that you know the
West is best basically this idea because
our ideology can fix all problems it's
not reasonable when you look at the
Historical records I mean one of um one
scholar called Navid Sheikh actually
done a piece it's called body count and
he was counting the amount of people
that died in each civilization and he
put the Western Civilization is the
highest and because you have things like
World War one and World War II and these
things were World War One World War II
and nationalistic conquests they were
not religiously inspired when you cannot
you can argue to what extent where World
War one was religiously inspired but
certainly Islam didn't was not a main
feature of the 30 million people that
died in World War One or however many
million people died in order to so the
point is that we're saying is that and
obviously you've got Concepts in the
west like Manifest Destiny and which I
think every single president of the
United States of America believed in
Westwood expansion these kind of things
the point is is that it's a proposition
that the ideology of the West can fix
our problems this is what we have an
issue with because what we're saying is
that if we look at the historical record
there is no evidence of that in fact
what has shown us is that there's more
Bloodshed individualism has caused More
Death like with all due respect I know
that you you do cherish individuals I'm
not saying everything is bad about it
but when when you have a society deplete
of a communitarian ethic
is bereft of a communitarian ethic then
you can have these issues and so so
these are conversations and I think you
are moving towards the communitarianism
your newest book you're talking about
institutions and these kind of things
and the respectful tradition and these
kind of things I'm not sure if I'm
reading you correctly but
these are the kinds of conversations I
think we need to have but on that point
I think
I don't want this to be interrogative
and I just want to introduce one thing
because I think it's important I think
Jordan you're very you're very kind and
uh and I understand I also watch the
message to Muslims and I thought there
were some problems with it definitely
okay but when you said there's an
elephant in the room that I want to
address my mind immediately went to
videos I've seen a view okay with with
some of your friends in the street and
suggesting violence and suggesting uh
aggressive actions against other
communities which in the west is
something that
let's say in Canada people don't do that
and that even though there might be
civil conflicts we have a state we have
police we have an apparatus yeah
which is not completely perfect which
which is functions to install the rules
so when I see someone in the street
surrounded by men wearing masks yes who
are talking about
if these other groups come out you know
they're going to see us and we're going
to be there and I'm looking for Jews and
we're talking about blood and there's
this very these very strange behaviors
that yeah we're looking for Jews you
remember that when I said that exact
same one I just remember you talking to
police about about Jewish people yeah I
would like to get an exact quote okay so
I don't remember we're cool so the other
one the one that I definitely saw that
that you spoke for quite a while was was
relating to some issues with Hindu so
what happened recently I don't want to
know
the reason why it's important I just the
reason why it's important is that yeah
is that I have met I'm a Christian very
much a Christian I have many problems
with modern Western culture yeah right
um and but we are in the west okay right
and you are in the west yeah and I am a
Westerner right you live in the west and
so and I'm British yes just like you're
a Canadian exactly yes and so that to me
the elephant in the room is part that's
part of the elephant in the room there
are many people who
not to come here because of those videos
okay well there's a lot of people that
told me not to have this conversation
with Jordan yeah and that's why me and
George people don't want to have
difficult conversations but what I'm
saying with Jordan is that that what
makes him gallant and brave is that
despite those voices that are the voices
of disunity
because he's been canceled more times
than I have yeah but despite the fact
that he's been canceled in Cambridge
University whatever I don't care about
all these institutions with all due
respect I know this man as a person of
influence and in my estimation I see him
as one of the most if not the most
influential Western public voice
right so for that reason I speak to him
and for that reason I don't apologize to
anyone for doing so and I think in in a
way he sees the same thing in Me Maybe
not to the same level
but the fact that I'm half his age
he knows what's going to come in a 30
years time so he's he's playing the
cards right and I think at the end of
the day my voice my emotions what I'm
saying in the Streets of London or
Leicester whatever else is how a lot of
Muslim people feel but don't forget yes
I'm disagreeable and I'm not that's my
temperament it's not the temperament of
the average Muslim so you've got to
differentiate between me as an
individual me Muhammad hijab was an
individual and Islam
do you see if you say Muhammad you are a
hypocrite you are a bad guy you are
violent so you know what that's
something I have to look into
you know what I mean if that's your
advice to me or something I would also
say that there's no moral advantage in
being a pushover either yes and so these
things are very hard to calibrate
correctly and so well and if we come at
this in a spirit of mutual ignorance and
with some degree of
maybe this is where tolerance is more of
an issue is you know we're going to have
to tolerate each other's rough edges and
Imperfections in order to talk even if
we think that there's something useful
to be gleaned and you know my sense is
that well we're called upon to separate
the wheat from the chaff and that's not
so much to damn the chaff as it is to
gather the wheat and it seems to be in
in the biblical stories in in the Old
Testament there's an immense emphasis
strange emphasis in some real sense it's
one of the things that makes the text so
remarkable on the
um moral stranger and Foreigner and so
when the society is unstable and shaking
in a variety of ways it's often
the moral Foreigner who comes in with
something wise to say and I think that's
definitely true of those biblical
narratives and it's very interesting
that they Point them out but I think
it's also true practically it's like
it's not as if any of us like we want to
have faith in our faith and we need that
because it keeps us together
individually and it unites us socially
but then if we insist that
my if I insist that my faith which is
more like my pride in my own belief is
100 correct then I've I've confused
myself with my faith my confused myself
with Christianity or perhaps you've
confused yourself with Islam and that's
a big mistake because so let me ask you
both a question then since
we can talk by the way one clarification
with the question I've never asked for
violence and that's that's an accusation
I think that needs to be uh you need to
look back at because I've never said
let's go and do violence I said that if
if such and such group come out again
which were a group of armed people then
we'll be there to defend the community I
don't I've never said in my whole life
and I'll challenge anybody to find
anything that's uh opposite from what
I've just said now that's one thing
second thing I'll say is this is that
and if it was a violence issue if I did
say that what's happening with the
Metropolitan Police why am I not behind
bars why have there well not been a
single investigation is 210 000 people
have watched a video unless the police
have put their you know fingers in their
ears or that they are if you want to
accuse the police of you know negligence
or incompetence that's a different story
let's go to the second point because you
were saying now about this basically
dogmatism let's just call it for what it
is like you know what's pride and
organism right and that's something we
all have to watch because it's a hard
line to walk because you want to be an
advocate for your faith but what world
do you know right you're ignorant Beyond
Comprehension on both of you this is a
question to both of you is there an
ultimate purpose of life
yeah sure what is it
what we're doing here which is what
hopefully trying to make peace
is that enough
we'll see yeah because if it's better
than the alternative what's the
alternative hell
okay which we're toying with I don't
mean us well us too that's for sure but
you know things are things are shaky at
the moment on many fronts and we have
this opportunity in front of us all of
us
to have a very abundant world right
where everyone has enough
and maybe more than enough
and we're we're shaky about that we're
not sure that that's acceptable and
we're not sure everybody should have it
we're not sure everybody deserves it and
even ourselves and
and we're retreating into our Corners in
some real sense and we're not addressing
the elephants under the carpet and you
can't do that like the things we're
discussing contentiously now you know
they make for rough conversations but
they make for a lot rougher streets if
you don't talk them out and you have to
do that a spirit of ignorance you know
like I was hoping to come here today and
well unless and I talk a lot there's my
flaw you know but
I don't know how to feel the Right Way
Forward I think part of it is well first
of all to find commonalities we believe
in in the fundamental necessity of a
uniting book across the Jewish Christian
and Muslim faiths that's not nothing
like that's a strange thing to insist
upon and yet we all seem to agree we
believe in a a higher and purposeful
Unity the necessity of that and then
also in the necessity of putting that
Above All Else and we also agree that
we're not very good at that but that's
the hardest one to get is that even if
you do
claim in some sense to worship
the highest
in this monotheistic sense that doesn't
mean you're very good at it and that's a
hard pill to swallow especially when
you're trying to also be a courageous
Knight of your faith let's say it's hard
to be
properly humble in the face of the
Divine but that might be in some sense
the proper command I mean the fact that
Islam means submission is a reflection
of that in some sense right just
remember who's God here and who isn't
and so and that's a very hard thing to
keep in mind so when I listen to you you
disagreeable character I'm trying to
separate out the wheat from the chaff
you know because there's no doubt I have
many things to learn as I learn to some
degree I appreciate this part of like
you know I learned from from your
humility honestly the way you come
across and once again I do appreciate
both of you coming here you know and I
appreciate this agreeability as well
like what you've said that's good I
deserve the accountability just like he
does I don't want to be a person who you
know who doesn't count this [ __ ] out who
dishes out well can't get it himself I
deserve it what I wanted to say is this
to both of you I want to do a full
experiment yeah and so imagine you're
going to sleep I don't know what you
guys are saying now what I'll tell you
about staying you're watching my videos
you know with me with the masks and
stuff like that before you go to sleep
subscribe on the channel whatever you do
yeah and now you're after you've you
know put the dislike and done your
negative comments which I deleted
already and put it in the trash
which is what you do is all the tweets
and you know we can talk about that
later but after that's all happened and
you've gone to sleep you both go to
sleep now right you wake up and you find
yourselves on a ship
on a ship yeah
and people are eating food people are
drinking people are this and that so
this is happening
now what would be the first questions
that you would ask
to people around you
would you ask things like how did I get
here where are we going is that are
these it does seem like the first yeah
those are good questions to ask in
general where are they how did we get
here and this is where are we going
beautiful that's what I wanted to
actually get to because this is what
Heidegger you know modern Heidegger he's
a controversial figure and it's all
right okay but he described this as the
thrownness of Life yeah because we're
chucked into life we're thrown into life
right so the fact now that we're in this
world
these questions that we'll be asking if
we were on a ship and were just chucked
on a ship well the same very questions
like you said you know that we would be
asking your phone as well in this world
where did we come from where are we
going I think if we can't get these two
questions right
nihilism will persist
you're a nihilistic expert you've spoken
a lot about nihilism I think if we can't
get those counter knives
if you want to ask my what I think my
purpose the purpose is is to be United
with God okay beautiful yeah beautiful
okay so from the Islamic perspective
it's this right first of all ask these
three questions where where do I come
from where am I going what am I doing
here what is the purpose of life
what is it and the answer is we came
from
a Creator okay
so we can't we can we can approach this
in whatever argument you like I'm doing
PhD in contingency argument you can do
anything you want you can do for example
through the the fact that the universe
is regular and stable and uniform and
possesses life what's the best
explanation for that is it knowledge or
not knowledge so you say it's knowledge
right or if you say it's a creative
capacity of some sort we came from this
creative capacity we came from this
knowledge Force right so that's the
first thing we'll say we came from this
Force this higher power where are we
going we're going back to the higher
power right and we're going back to the
higher power with our feeds which we
have to be responsible for which is
exactly it's a Hallmark of what you
stand for and that's I believe genuinely
that's why you're asking why are so many
people listening to you
because we reject original sin would you
respect original sin says that one man
yeah gave us gave us a sin the other man
took it away basically I mean we're
falling creatures and then Jesus You've
Got to Believe In the solo feeder you
believe in whatever you you know what
comes so I don't believe that oh fair
enough okay I don't believe in original
sin the way you described it fine no no
Norwich it's an orthodox yeah yeah okay
fine but the the issue is that this I
didn't say I believe didn't either I
just said that these the concept of
original sin is an expression of this
problem that we're describing which is
that we're all burdened with something
approximating while the thrownness and
this ambivalent relationship we have
with the atrocity of history and but and
that's worse because if you study the
atrocity of history with any degree of
seriousness you have to take account of
the fact that people like you did it and
you might think well I wouldn't do it
it's like yeah I get you I wouldn't be
so sure about that for sure I mean you
know you were talking about the kind of
you you were talking about the suffering
and we're obviously one of the major
sufferings is the Holocaust I was
reading the book the meaning for Life
Victor Frank I'm sure you're aware of it
where he then produced logo therapy and
all these kind of things and it goes
back to what Nietzsche said you know if
you have a why almost any how is
possible you know bearable yeah if you
have a why almost any house possible so
it goes back to everything goes back to
purpose logo therapy yeah just if you
have a purpose then everything is
possible that's why I think that you can
do the best as a human species yeah in
The Human Condition if your purpose is
Transcendental it's higher than the
physical the material and for us the
purpose is mentioned chapter 51 verse 19
of the Quran which is
we have not created human beings and gin
except for that they may worship me what
is worship it's the epitome the higher
point of submission is the epitome of
love as well
Jonathan has an interesting take on that
too that has to do with celebration
which I think is psychologically
appropriate do you want to I don't want
to put you on the spot but but it's it's
an it's something I've been struggling
to understand more I attended some
Orthodox ceremonies with Jonathan and
also on my own and and he's he's very uh
perspicacious when it comes to
describing the role of both worship and
ritual and so there's an element anyways
I'll let you continue with that no I
agree I agree that worship is also the
manner in which we bind together right
and so without something we celebrate
together then we then we don't and so we
have different levels of what we
celebrate you know we can celebrate in
our families and the things that bind us
but ultimately that has to reach the all
the way up into something which is
beyond I think that's actually very
powerful you know and in fact the first
very first lines of the Quran is
alhamdulillah which is all praise and
thanks belong to God lord of the worlds
all praise and all thanks and this is a
kind of Celebration this is a kind of
Praise You know we we agree that
praising God at the highest level
celebrating God I mean the word
hallelujah well I would say in some
sense if we're doing that well there was
some comments at the beginning about the
importance of music yeah and you opened
this event with music and I've been
beginning to open my events with music
and part of the reason that that's very
much worthwhile and has to do with this
drum beat that underlies everything is
that music is a manifestation of
something like the joyful Spirit of
harmonious play and it's not semantic
right it grips you and it says I heard
you say something before about this you
said that music was impervious to
representation it's impervious to Russia
the meaning of music is impervious to
router yeah I'd say that was a very
powerful way
to know you know and so with with with a
musical manner in which the Quran is
presented a major part of that yes is
the music music and the music speaks we
know the music music speaks of layers of
patterned Harmony and you talked about
the individualism of the West and I
think that
that there's a there's a there's a flaw
in that
particularized conception that needs to
be addressed by something that's more
approximating a communitarian ethos and
I think you can understand that
relationship to music because look to
some degree the three of us can sit on
stage and everyone in the audience we
can be comfortable at the moment
psychologically so we're not too anxious
and we're kind of engaged because
there's a certain degree of playful
Harmony that we've established
especially with him yeah so it's so this
is
right but we're able to integrate that
and so that means we can remain calm and
so one of the things that indicates is
that part of our ability to remain calm
and focused is dependent on social
integration so you have to ask yourself
well could you be saying if your
marriage was insane could you be saying
if your children with if your
relationship with your children was too
fractious could you be saying if you had
no friends if you didn't integrate
yourself into the community and maybe
the state and then maybe a higher Vision
And as far as I can tell the answer to
that is no you can't be saying by
yourself it's not merely a matter of
psychological integration it's not
merely a matter of
of of the isolated individual and of
course we understand that in the west
although perhaps not as well as we
should formally because we'll punish
criminals for example by putting them in
in solitary confinement and that's
another indication of the impossibility
of maybe if you're an expert meditator
and a religious man you could tolerate
the solitude but you probably wouldn't
be a criminal then so my point is is
that I I view this process of
integration as a multi-layered process
that involves the integration of the
community all the way up to the highest
place and yes and about how this place
has to be a Unity as Jonathan pointed
out or or we're divided and so we might
want to seek amongst us as much as we
can for a common Unity at least start
with that and so and that's what we're
trying to do in this conversation yes
but Unity is different it's uniformity
so yes I see the difference being is
that you know in the Islamic
discussion or discourse it's like there
is this there's a verse in the Quran in
fact this is you have your religion we
have ours there is we can demarcate and
still tolerate that's the point and I
say appreciate even yeah even appreciate
that would be good people love each
other
I mean that's the thing going back to
the message of Muslims I think this is
where classical question have you ever
been to a Muslim country yes which ones
have you been to I've been to Morocco
and I've been to Turkey and uh have I
been to any other Muslim countries not
yet okay there's many on the itinerary
go to go to a Muslim country with a
Christian population I'm from I'm
originally from Egypt yeah we've we've
we've had Coptic Christians there for
years yeah we've had them 400 years I
mean they were there before the Muslims
came right and the point is is that if
you go to Ghana go to Nigeria this Bleak
image of Muslims and Christians kind of
fighting each other I don't think that's
what's really going on I'm not saying
that there's no grievance there when the
Christian Community is in Muslim
majority lands yeah be a lie and that
would be false and that can easily be
just refuted why I'm saying is that it's
not as bad as you think if you go to
these countries you will not find I do
not think you will find what's going on
for example you're talking about Hindus
in India with the Muslim minorities in a
Hindu supposedly you know majority which
is a peaceful religion what's going on
there what's going on China with the
Muslim minority there or for example may
I add like so say but what's happening
in Palestine as well so yeah I don't I
don't want to paint any large-scale
Endeavor with the brush that's let's say
dipped in the blood of its worst
excesses I don't think that's helpful
because then we're all irredeemable in
some real sense I think it's much wiser
for us to
see what we do see what we can jointly
celebrate and see if we can manage that
in something like a spirit of of
ignorance and hope you know because one
of the things I learned a long time ago
it was very helpful for me as a
clinician was that if everything wasn't
perfect around me all the time
it was probably at least in part because
I was much less than I could conceivably
be and one of the things I learned from
Carl Jung who's a great thinker was that
what you need most will be found where
you least want to look
and yes well and it's almost by
definition right because you can imagine
that you're most likely to be most
ignorant about what you're most afraid
of and most contemptuous of and so by
definition that's the last place you
want to look and if you're an advocate
of a given religious Faith one of the
last places you might want to look is in
the wisdom of an alternative faith I
agree so but you know that's well who
are you to be such a such a committed
advocate of a faith that's so complex
that there's no way that someone like
you can understand it and I mean that of
your own faith and so it's not so ever
it's not so obvious that the stranger
you think is the devil doesn't have
something to say I get you but yeah I
once heard you quote Carl Young because
obviously you you mentioned him a lot in
your books and I learned a lot from
youth about Carl Jung yeah that he
stated that you know the West
are technological Giants but moral
dwarfs in comparison yeah yeah so and
that's the problem all over the world
increasingly right we're technological
Giants to some extent but what I was
going to say here is that
going back to Carl Jung here because for
example and going back to the issue of
purpose yeah if we're speaking about
purpose
I watched your discussion with Sam
Harris and you were speaking about
yourself the last one no there was one
that you've done I don't know what it
wasn't that famous you weren't speaking
to him like this but there was a there
was one point of it which really was
like it gave me an insight into your I
don't want to be a psychologist here
right but again maybe maybe I dare say
it gave me an insight into your
psychological State because you Sam
Harris he said to you he said um
your conception of pragmatism that truth
is malleable or whatever so it's not
it's not one capital T truth like well
there's no I said more that I don't
believe that the most fundamental truth
is objective yeah in a scientific sense
and I don't think it can be yeah so so
in that sense the your perspective and
you know this as well is more
epistemologically pragmatist rather than
correspondence theory right so
correspondence theory says that one one
truth out there I think correspondence
theories have to be nested under
pragmatic theories in some real so
you're saying the same thing as the
American pragmatist said
yes very much what I was going to say
with that he said if you believe in this
yeah it will be at your peril and you
know what you said you responded you
retorted you said it has been in my
Peril you said it has not let me let's
let's focus on this because this is
actually deep you said it has been at my
peril
because I heard your voice and I heard
now these words stuck in my mind yeah
you said it has been at my peril now let
me let me submit something to you today
could it be that it's like your peril
because if you don't believe it in Truth
with a capital T in the correspondence
theory sense that there is a God and
that's a true statement just like two
plus equals four is a true statement
just like just like they're geocentric
the heliocentric model is a true
statement in that sense there is a God
out there and he created the world he
created you he's sustaining the universe
he is maintaining the universe there is
a true statement and that is in a
correspondent serious sense if you don't
have that level of certainty
then you'll end up being an existential
angst and and you will end up being
depressed because that's what the Quran
says the Quran says
whoever trans whoever swerves away from
my remembrance will have a depressed
life so I think that ever well I think
almost by definition when you Veer from
a path oriented towards the highest
Unity that you fall apart
it's by definition you know I don't know
what that means specifically with
regards to a correspondence theory
because the correspondence theorists
tend to be more oriented towards a
materialist Viewpoint and that doesn't
seem to me to work out very well when
discussing something like God do I think
that we strive towards a higher Unity
that that Unity is real and that it's
necessary there's no contradiction in
having correspondence theory in dualism
or idealism it doesn't have to be
materialism because that would indicate
the truth uh the truth of preempiracism
well I would say then my answer to that
is that I try to act as if that's true
and I I think I say I act as if it's
true because I don't I'm not in a
position to make any final judgments in
some real sense but I am in a position
to stake my life on certain faith-based
propositions that's what you can do that
doesn't mean you're right but that's
what you have your disposal and so I am
trying to do that to feel the proper way
forward
in this Spirit of let's say playful
Unity yes and to put that above all else
which is partly why I also said that I
did that's my Peril the thing is what I
would say is that if you take the
proposition that truth is utility yeah
and what is useful is that which is true
that's basically the American pragmatist
stance
if you take that if well it's not
exactly not exactly well there see I
think that's what Charles Pierce said
almost by word I know I know I know yeah
um the pragmatists are more like
Engineers which is well you can't build
a perfect Bridge because what do you
know you can't build anything perfect
but you can build a bridge that's a
bridge insofar as it will stand up and
allow you to walk across it for 400
years and so and then then the notion
there is well
it's not perfect it doesn't correspond
precisely to the ultimate nature of
reality let's say but it's good enough
to move you from point A to point B and
so yes but the the going back to Victor
Frankel and the idea of meaning yeah
what I'm saying is I know you're a
psychoanalysis analyst
uh this from the quranic Paradigm this
will not be enough meaning based on your
current paradigm
according to the Islamic diagnosis you
will be depressed why because your
purpose is not strong enough
do you see the point yes well that's
probably true I know that sounds a bit
intrusive so I do apologize for that but
I don't I don't think it is intrusive
from that from that orientation towards
Unity then yes I know this from a
psychological perspective if you deviate
from orientation toward the highest
Unity which you might think about as the
highest goal yes two things happen one
is you're you experience less positive
emotion so joy and enthusiasm and
engagement because positive emotion is
experienced in relation to a goal not as
a consequence of achieving it yes so if
you're pursuing the highest goal then
you're celebrating most intently and
then if the goal you're pursuing isn't
unified then it's multiplicitous and
then you're confused and anxious and
unstable and depressed exactly I would
say that's by definition well I was
reading uh recently I've read all your
books and I've even read some of your
peer-reviewed work because when I was
going to speak to you then I said you
know I'm going to do my homework
so I read everything one of the things
that you said one time in the maps of
meaning
you started off the book by saying when
you were a young lad I don't know how
how young you were you said that
you found the doctrines of Christianity
incomprehensible and absurd yeah and you
also said that you found you had some
kind of issue with Christianity because
of the Genesis narrative and how in
incongruent it was with scientific
narratives you went to a pastor you said
or a church clerical sign and then you
left the church now I've got a question
do you still have the same position or
have you changed your position well I've
changed my position a lot I was only 13
then you know I was I was caught up in
in
the battle you know to in so far it was
manifested in me when I was 13 I was
caught in the battle between
Enlightenment rationality and
traditional narrative belief I had no
idea how to reconcile those two things
do you feel like he can do that no
I'm doing my best to reconcile yes and I
think well I certainly can do it a lot
more than I did when I was 13. let me
give you an example right this this
point when you were 13 I think you were
thinking straight I'll be I'm sorry to
be very straight man it's hard to
believe that someone is disagreeable
with you as you imagine because someone
with an IQ of 180 whatever you have yeah
someone of your intelligence when you
were 13 you probably had an IQ of I
don't know 120 or something yeah so he
was you were operating like my friend
over here I said it's on his level we're
at the age of 13. but what I was going
to say was that you know
the reason why I think he was because
look at the Trinity for example look at
the schisms now this goes to your
specialism that the idea of three
all-powerful entities that Jesus is
all-powerful that the father is all
power the son is all powerful the holy
spirit is all powerful but there's not
all what there's not three or powerfuls
there's one more powerful you have one
ultimately willing being with your
person which is Jesus another person
which is ultimately willing which is the
son the Quran States about this
in chapter 23 verse number one 91 it
says that Allah has not taken any son
and he doesn't he did not have any
creator with him
had that been the case they would have
stripped one another for what they would
have competed and tried to outstrip one
another for power meaning this idea of
three all-powerful persons is
unintelligible to say the least the idea
that Jesus Christ exhibits two Natures
for I know that there are schisms and
there's difference opinion among
Christians but the fact that you have
this Human Nature
where Jesus is walking and he sees the
tree and he can't eat from the tree he
doesn't know that the tree is uh in
season or not although he doesn't know
when the hour is or whatever it may be
the Quran says it very clearly
time him and his mom used to eat food
this proposition that they are limited
and unlimited at the same time is a
contradiction it's an affront to logic
that's it this will cause you cognitive
dissonance because if you want to be a
rational actor and you want to be that's
the thing yeah yeah I don't want to be a
rational actor but you do when you do
your scientific experiments that's true
so why'd you why'd you separate the two
things
because rationality shouldn't be
subordinated to something above it and
I'm trying to subordinate myself to that
and so my my reaction to what you're
saying
um is that
it's an in this isn't an insult yeah I'm
telling you what my reaction is please
it's not it's not even a criticism of
course I find the discussion that
discussion as soon as it started I found
that less interesting than what we were
doing before it was harder for me to
focus on and I I think the reason for
that is that
it it it transforms to some and I'm not
saying this isn't necessary sometimes
but it transforms the Transcendent into
something like an intellectual and
propositional discussion and so in some
sense we're debating perhaps not the
fine points of theology because they're
more like the blunt points of theology
but there's something about that that
there's something about that that isn't
what I want to do with you yes you know
and it isn't that it's not necessary so
let me flip it around right so I agree
so one of the things I'm very curious
about is obviously the figure of Christ
is contentious yes and so the Jews don't
know what to make of Christ in some
fundamental sense because he seems like
the last
he seems like and what would you a
continuation of the prophetic tradition
in some real sense plus he was Jewish so
that makes things complicated and then
of course the Christians put the figure
of Christ as as Central in some real
sense but that begs the question of the
relationship between Christ and God and
then in the Muslim Community Christ is
also a central figure and so I'm curious
about that and we could say we have
doctrinal differences about what
constitutes that centrality it's like
fair enough and I would also not say
that I understand
what that centrality means like so one
of the ways I would understand that
let's say is that
in in the western tradition and I don't
know to what degree this is true in the
Muslim tradition one of the
attributes of what Christ is
psychologically is the logos and so if
we're engaged in dialogue which is
dual logos then we're embodying the
spirit of something like Mutual
Enlightenment and that's then the
presence of that spirit in the in the
genuine confines of temporal reality
right it's something like the infinite
descending to the finite to illuminate
us and to the degree that we can have a
dialogue in good faith which is also a
religious notion then we can engage in
that process of dialogues and that
transforms and redeems us and then when
I say well do I believe that I say well
it isn't just that I believe it as a
proposition it's that I can tell when
it's happening and so can you I think is
like you're going to see that this
conversation will ebb and flow you know
and some of the time it's going to grip
you you think we're at the heart of the
matter and sometimes your attention is
going to wander your attention is going
to wander when we're off the path and so
I would say that yes to the degree that
you and I are communicating this is a
religious way of thinking about it is
that we're doing our best to embody the
spirit of the logos and if that's
working then we're making progress and I
know that in the western tradition
that's part of what has been
conceptualized as the fundamental
attribute of of the figure of Christ and
I know that Christ is Central in the
Muslim tradition and so one of the
things I would want to know is not how
we differ doctrinally yeah because I
don't even think I'm qualified to to
debate you on that case I got the guy
here well you might have some things to
say but yeah but what I would like to to
know instead is why do you believe that
the figure of Christ is Central in some
sense or maybe I've got that wrong
although I don't think so why do you
think the figure of Christ is Central
both to the Muslim faith and the
Christian faith and what do you think
that says about what we share in common
because I really don't understand that
it's a mystery to me okay so Jesus
Christ if secular historians will look
at him and differ on his existence or
not the majority to be fair do believe
he existed right the even second hand
stores atheists on agnostics and
whatever it may be right it's the
simplest explanation yeah it's a simple
of course yeah so I believe that first
of all Jesus Christ existed which in the
modern age is worth noting right Muslims
actually Muslims only the only other
major world religion who believe in will
Jesus Christ as the Messiah as the
prophet right yeah this is a strange
thing so we should definitely be trying
to sort that out all right so this is
the first point of commonality we
believe in Jesus Christ we believe in
his miracles that he cured the blind of
God's permission that he raised the Dead
with God's permission we believe that he
even you know uh he he created some
things which in the Gospel of Thomas
nomish in the Bible like you know but uh
for example the the clay bird and so on
that he blew into it and it became an
actual bird that he killed the leper
with God's permission we believe that he
was one of the mightiest human beings
that have ever lived on the earth and we
believe that his mother was the best
woman who ever lived on the earth the
Quran actually explicitly says that well
that seems like a good starting point
right and so that is the first thing we
believe when we look at the quranic
verses relating to Jesus Christ we don't
look at those metaphorically no
Orthodox Muslim normatively looks at
those in an ecological way it's not
physiology for us it's it's it's history
so we believe that this is actually
historical that's the first thing and
the reason why I mentioned that to you
is because
I I listen to all of your biblical
series I think a lot of Muslims have and
yeah a lot of people like it it's
because obviously yeah strangely enough
and no and it's not very strange if you
know the Quran because the Quran
actually tells us to go to the people of
the book and to to listen to them and to
you know and you'll find an exegesis
like for example
like one of the staple exegesis of the
Quran they use uh Biblical verses all
the time let's go to the people of the
book let's see what information they
have a tabari mentions what you call it
which is basically passages from the
Bible passages from the uh Torah and so
on like that from the biblical tradition
and from the Torah so it's not really
it's not it's not abnormal for Muslim
people to be interested in Christian
explanations that's been going on for a
thousand three hundred years yeah that's
the first thing the second thing is that
why because symbolism is important and
you've mentioned for example Egyptian
symbolism you mentioned for example
oracists and I don't know Isis and all
this not that Isis
but you know the Egyptian goddesses I
have to make that very clear
um and so on yeah so my question would
be their fault before we talk about
symbolism because a symbol can be
something you can have a symbol
and an expression of something which
exists at the same time for example you
can have something which is metal not
metaphoric because you can't have a
metaphor and numbers for example but you
can't have a symbol and something which
doesn't for example I say that you are a
symbol for Western and whatever it is uh
intellectualism yeah possibly I mean
debate is Jordan priest and a symbol for
Western debate it
um and he exists now here's the point
like you know you know that there are
Central doctrines to Christianity like
the crucifixion the Ascension the
resurrection and all the all the above
right these are doctrines how do we look
at these doctrines because the reason
why I'm asking you I think you are
qualified though at least you have some
because you did mention in your lectures
that you were taking the approach of the
alexandrian school which is like origin
of Alexander in his Jewish teacher
fellow and these kinds of people who
take what you call the spiritualizing
text they spiritualize the text they
were known the alexandrian school was
known for spiritualizing the text and
they were aborational in that in that
sense and that's why one of the reasons
why they were seeing the theoretics by
the by all I think all the churches
these
the origin said some things which are
heretical but he has massive influence
on Church fathers that are respected but
uh you should do your point yeah the the
the let's say the notion that that uh
facts have meaning that is something
that as Christians we should believe yes
right is that God created the world with
the meaningful structure so the world
lays itself out in a way that when we
see it we can see them exactly and this
is something which all all types of
Christians will agree with Catholics
will do the Eastern Orthodox and
Protestants all of them will say You
Must Believe In These doctrines as
happening you cannot believe in them as
symbol you cannot believe so the reason
why this actually so when I when I hear
something like that then the question
that arises for me is what do you mean
happening and so so let me just unpack
that a little bit so I did a lecture
last night at the Apollo on the story of
Cain and Abel yes and one of the things
that I
proposed was that
not only did that story happen
but it's
it's always happening yes it always
happened it's happening right now and
it's always going to happen into the
future and so I would say to some degree
the mirror reduction of these profound
stories to a historical reality is an
underestimate of their truth because
they're a strange kind of truth because
they're the truth that always happened
and is happening now and always will
happen so you're thinking Bible story
for example do you have a story of the
eternal battle between something like
the spirit of joyful and appropriate
sacrifice which is characterizes Abel
and the spirit of resentful resentment
against the structure of existence as a
consequence of thrownness and the
shaking of the fist at God and that's
always happening because for all of us
you know we look at our lives and we
think well should we be happy to be
alive should we be grateful to be alive
and the answer to that is often but not
always and if you put someone in the
position of job and he's being tortured
to death by fate and tragedy and
catastrophe and malevolence he might
well come to a point where he's
motivated to take the resentful path and
shake his fisted God and we have those
Spirits inside of us warring constantly
and so when and so then when I look at a
story like Cain and Abel I think well
the question did that happen
begs the question what do you mean by
happen because when you are dealing with
fundamental realities and you pose a
question you have to understand that the
reality of the concepts of your question
when you're digging that deep are just
as questionable about as what you're
questioning you know so people say to me
what do you do you believe in God and I
think okay there's a couple of mysteries
in that question what do you mean do
what do you mean you what do you mean
believe and what do you mean God and you
say as the questioner well we already
know what all those things mean except
belief in God and I think no if we're
going to get down to the fundamental
brass tax we don't really know what any
of those things mean and so for me
believe for example is often reflected
not so much in proposition as it is in
action if I want to know what you
believe I could ask you and hopefully
you have some idea about what you
believe but I'd rather see what you do
what can I can I can I push back a
little bit with this because like for
example when I was reading your book uh
your newest book actually this time yeah
it's 12 more rules they're very good
books by the way I mean I recommend them
honestly and buy them if you haven't
already bought them
it's I was I would specifically
recommend the 12 rules for life because
the 12 more rules I have some criticisms
of it but it's good it's a good book but
one thing you did say about it you're
really hard to believe that you're
disagreeable really yeah
[Laughter]
um so one thing you mentioned in the in
the book you were talking about some
psychological theory which I don't
forget I forget what it is what it is
right now you mentioned something you
said this you know the problem with this
such and such Theory
is that it doesn't have any evidence
full stop categorical
all this what you're doing now you
didn't mention that you didn't say well
it depends on what you mean by this it
depends on what you're sorry to say
again but it depends on what you mean by
this it depends what you mean you become
postponed all of a sudden it's like you
become now you've been yeah that's a
definite oh yeah that's a definite look
I think that's partly why the postmodern
critique in some sense was inevitable is
because we started to dig down into
something like say the meaning of
stories because that's really where the
postmodernists got their impetus because
the post-modern literary theorists sorry
to drag this up but it's relevant
they hit a mystery which was
well if you read a given text story or
even a paragraph and you get a hundred
people to offer their opinion on it in
some way you get a hundred different
opinions and you can tell that if you
assign students to write an essay let's
say and so then a problem emerges as if
well if there's a hundred different
opinions and some of them even appear to
oppose one another how do you know what
the true significance is of the text and
then worse how do you even know that
there is a true significance
and then that and then you think okay
well that's a that's a major problem and
then here's a worse problem imagine you
have an assemblage of texts like like
the biblical Corpus let's say which is
really a library and it's in some sense
canonical right well if you can decide
on the fixed meaning of even a given
paragraph how in the world can you make
the statement that this
selection of texts which are much more
complicated than just paragraphs is
somehow canonical now the answer to that
is this is the answer we don't know now
the problem with the postmodernists
wasn't that they figured out that this
was a mystery because not only is this
the mystery of textual interpretation
which is a major mystery how do we
understand the text but it's also in the
mystery of perception because at the
same time people who are investigating
perception Jonathan has been talking
about this with John varvakia cognitive
scientist at the same time scientists on
the perceptual front in AI labs and and
neuroscientists were discovering that
it's so complicated to look at the world
which is to interpret the world let's
say that it isn't obvious that it's even
possible which is partly why we don't
have autonomous robots they can't see
the world now it's easy for us because
we just look at it but that's not so
easy and so
well so what's the point of all this
well the point of all this is that if
you delve into questions deeply enough
you do run into the problem of
perception and the multitude and
multiplicity of perception and that's a
real problem and so when I do something
like an interrogate a question well the
postmodern problem does emerge now I've
been trying to work out solutions to
that and and Jonathan and I and John
vervacci have been discussing this a lot
the post-modernists were correct I think
in their diagnosis of the problem they
leapt right to the idea that the way we
solve the problem of perception is by
exercising power they just took a
Marxist story and said well there's the
solution by in particular mostly the
French intellectual types
yeah I would I would disagree with this
by the way I don't think the derida of
Foucault took amongst his position at
all well Jonathan you want to have that
that's true but that's not my fight it's
a worthless victory for me are you sure
you have to talk about that no no I
don't like I don't care okay well well
we can either delve into that or not let
me just say something and learn about
what you what you were saying that is I
think that when there's this question of
do you believe in God I think one of the
problems that Jordan no yeah the the the
difficulty that Jordan faced was faced
with a modern protestantism which was
very propositional and it was like just
I believe and it's just a bunch of
things that you believe in in terms of
of thinking and I do think that
what Jordan is
trying to grasp at and trying to
understand is actually probably closer
to something that most traditional
Muslims would believe which is that it
if you say that you submit to God but
you don't submit to God then that word
is and I agree with yes so the question
is why is it empty right if you said the
words why is it still empty and so the
so I think that what he's grasping at is
to find a more encompassing it's like
stop asking me if I believe in God watch
me yeah okay no but I get what you're
saying but what I'm saying is this is
that the attitude that you have towards
scientific investigation is that which
is more congruent with a correspondent
stereotype yes right so you you simply
asked the question that by the way the
Quran asks and one of the questions
Central questions the Quran asks us to
ask Christians and Jews is
bring your evidence if you're truthful
this is the central question that
Muslims are asked to ask the same
question that you as a scientist ask we
have to ask as well right now I'm using
what I'm saying is this is where the
cognitive dissonance may come in
so that is part of what's torn in the
west apart on say on the basis of the
Enlightenment versus the religious
tradition to agree that that's a con
just to add to this point is for example
going back to origin of Alexandria
origin of Alexandria because he has this
hermeneutical dilemma he has a
homological dilemma right he doesn't
know what to do with what verse is he
going to spiritualize that metaphorizer
or is he not going to do that he was
asked by an apologist called celsus he
said what do you say of the crucifixion
and he responds to the effect to an
effect to say that not everything was
true what happened right in the
crucifixion point is that when you open
the can of worms of homological
spiritualization or exegetical or you
know metaphorization yeah when you open
that kind of worms what is left of
Christianity is basically mythological
now then I will say what makes this myth
better than any other myth what's why
are we investigating the myth of
Christianity and not for example the
myth of Hercules and Zeus why is uh the
figure of Father and Son and Holy Spirit
more important to me than the mithric uh
would you call it Trinity yeah well
that's a post-modern question and you
could take that even farther and say
well why this story rather than that
story at any level of story and that is
a central question how would you answer
because why did you for example you've
done a Biblical collection yeah so why
have you done a Biblical collection not
a lecture on Zeus and this and all these
well I have done lectures on on other
religious structures particularly on
engine Egyptian cosmology and on
Mesopotamian cosmology and I'm going to
do a lecture
sorry could you consider the biblical
narrative as as as having any level of
superiority over the other well okay
okay so so let me let me try to address
this cycle even he's interested
I am a Christian so so I've been trying
to understand so I'll tell you one thing
that clinical psychologists have learned
over the last hundred years despite
their doctrinal differences so there's
many schools of Clinical Psychology
ranging from behaviorism which is very
practical and strategic and has to do
with micro changes in action to
psychoanalytic theory say on the jungian
side which is more interested in dreams
and large-scale transformations of the
imagination spreads spans a huge range
of philosophies and practical approaches
but
there is one commonality
and it's emerged I would say empirically
the behaviorists first discovered the
behaviors discovered that if someone was
afraid of something and avoiding it and
the combination of those two things are
important because there's lots of things
you should be afraid of that you should
avoid like playing in traffic because
you'll just die if you go run out in the
street but imagine that you're moving
towards a necessary goal
and you're pretty committed to it and
something comes up that you're afraid of
and it stops you and now you start to
avoid okay and then maybe that gives you
an anxiety disorder it makes you
depressed then the question is what are
you avoiding and why and what should you
do about it and what the behavior has
started to do was to expose people to
small doses of what they were afraid of
and get them to relax and the idea was
well if you could learn to relax in the
face of what you were afraid of then the
fear would go away and maybe you had
learned in some way to associate that
with anxiety earlier now it turned out
that that worked but it also turned out
that it worked even if you didn't relax
and so there wasn't a learning to be
calm and then the psychoanalyst said now
that's not going to work behaviorists
because you'll expose someone to this
little fear and because the true fear is
much deeper the fear will just
re-emerged somewhere else they called
that symptom substitution and that
didn't happen either because what
happened weirdly enough was that if you
got someone to confront something they
were afraid of voluntarily
then they got less afraid
that was the first Theory less afraid of
a whole bunch of things so a little
courage generated more and that's a more
accurate way of thinking about it turns
out people didn't get less afraid they
got braver
and so their personality started to
expand and so what you see often one
category of people who often develop
anxiety disorders are dependent women
and so those are women who've gone from
sort of superordinate man to
superordinate man who've never
established a sufficient individual
identity and maybe that comes back to
haunt them later in life and they
develop an anxiety disorder and maybe
they're afraid to get into an elevator
so you can teach them to confront the
elevator and to get in it and to take it
and then they'll go home and have a
fight with their husband
and it's because they're braver and
often the husband and the rest of the
family will resist This Woman's attempt
to become more courageous because they
know what's going to happen if it's
successful but what that is what you see
is you see generalization of bravery and
that's and every psychological School
knows this okay so now you asked me a
theological question so I'm going to
address that so I've been trying to
understand from a psychological
perspective for example why people have
been gazing on the figure of the
crucifix for two thousand years now not
everyone and and doctrinal differences
apart it's still many people for two
thousand years and that begs a question
obviously there's something about that
image that's gripping okay so now you
might think why well why do people go to
horror movies because that's pretty
strange why in the world would you go be
disgusted and terrified because that's
sort of the essence of horror and the
answer is because there are terrifying
and disgusting things about life and
maybe you should go confront them now
and then voluntarily so get a little
taste so you can build a little
courage and a little faith and so at
minimum one of the things that the
crucifixion story The Passion story
represents is something like the sum of
all possible tragedy
and so young pointed out that the
passion narrative was an archetypal
tragedy and this is what he meant by
that imagine that you took a bunch of
stories that were tragic and so you
could identify them all as tragic
stories and a tragic story is something
like something terrible happens to
someone who doesn't deserve it that's a
tragedy so then imagine you have 10
stories about maybe someone got betrayed
by his best friend and someone fall prey
to a tyranny tyranny and someone died
young and someone innocent was punished
by a court and you'd think oh that's
tragic and then you took all those
tragedies and you took the core of the
tragedy and you made it into one story
and that's
in some sense what the passion story is
it's the sum of all possible tragedies
insofar as that can be construed by the
revelatory imagination and then you
might say well why gaze upon that well
the reason for that there's a story in
Exodus it's in numbers actually whether
Israelites are lost in the desert like
we all are and people are losing faith
because they're in the desert and you
know
and not
and and not voluntarily in some true
sense and so they're losing faith
they're getting all fractious they're
fighting they're starting to worship
false Idols they're falling apart and
God gets irritated at that
and so he sends a bunch of poisonous
snakes in to bite them and you think
well why would God do that it's like
well have you been alive you know
perfectly well that if you're confused
and lost and then you get bitter and
disunited that all you do is make things
worse and that more snakes come up to
bite you that's like that's life and so
the Israelites come to Moses and they
say
you seem to be in quite nicely with God
do you want to ask him to call off the
snakes like we're sorry get him to call
off the snakes and so Moses has a chat
with god let's say and and and God says
he doesn't call off the snakes and so
that's thing about God is very often he
doesn't call off the snakes you know
and he says instead to Moses that you
have to make a staff you have to cast a
staff out of bronze and on the staff you
have to place a serpent and then all the
Israelites have to go and look at the
serpent and if they look at the serpent
then they'll no longer be poisoned by
the snakes and and then there's a
section in the gospels where Christ says
something approximating that unless his
figure be lifted up like the serpent in
the desert no one can be redeemed unless
his figure is lifted up like the serpent
in the desert was a very strange thing
to have happen right because it's a
reference to this very strange story
that's ancient in a very strange context
many thousands of years later but can
imagine this it's like it's a bad thing
to be confronted with snakes and and
there's a real reason that the symbol
for medical transformation is a stake on
a snap on a staff right and and not just
associated with the judeo-christian
tradition it's a much older idea than
that
and so while there's snakes and that's
bad and you should look at them
but then there's something like the sum
total of all possible snakes
and that would be all the terrible
things that could happen to you in life
and then you could think well maybe you
need a story that
encompasses
that territory of terrible things
that you can then look on
and that's at least in part what the
passion story represents now you can
debate about whether or not it's a full
account of the
comprehensive tragedy of life but I like
I said I'm thinking about it
psychologically now there's more to it
because around that story there's also a
cloud of
mythology of associated imagery and and
one of those
developed dreams is something like the
harrowing of hell so not only does
Christ die terribly despite not only
being Innocent but being good and being
betrayed and being subject to tyranny
and having to die
it before the eyes of his mother all of
that but that's not enough
that hell itself has to be confronted I
would say well is that true of your life
it's like well
terrible things are going to happen to
you
and you better be prepared and then you
might think well that's too much and if
it's not too much it's at least enough
and I would say yeah that would be good
to believe but I don't think it's true
because you're actually going to have to
do something like
confront the reality at least of
historical atrocity and human hell
because that's part of your character
too and in order to fully reveal what
you could be
then you have to contend with all of
that and you have to do it voluntarily
and so part of the reason I'm interested
in that the Christian story let's say is
because
it that part of the story is where they
the rubber hits the road in some sense
it's like well that's your
responsibility is to confront the
catastrophe and hellish aspect of life
forthrightly and then the question is is
that transformative and one answer is
what did nature say you know you can
tell the character of a man's Spirit by
determining how much truth he can
tolerate it's a very interesting way of
thinking about it this is a crushing
weight this notion but
life is going to throw its catastrophes
at you sometimes even if you're innocent
and if you're not
prepared you know in faith well you're
going to fold and then it's going to be
much worse and how much do you have to
face and the answer might be every bit
of it do you know on this point thank
you for that I think that you've really
expressed that in a very powerful way
and what the last comment that you made
really was
um reminded me of a prophetic saying of
the Prophet Muhammad he said
wondrous is the if wondrous is the
affair of the believer
wondrous is the affair of the believer
all of his Affairs
and this is not afforded to anybody
except for the True Believer in
if good happens to him he is thankful
when asab
and if negative things happen to him he
is patient and he's thankful right
that's a hard thing to pull off the
powerful thing is and this is what
Nietzsche was a great advocate for
ironically he's a you know father of
postmodernism in a sense but he was
talking about human suffering yeah as a
positive thing for the resilience of
building of resilience and human being
and this
goes back to the point of purpose yeah
well you know one so here's another
thing that psychologists have learned so
imagine that you take a group of people
and you subject them to a difficult and
onerous and stressful task but you've
you've allowed you've set up the
experiment so one group has that
inflicted on them let's say and the
other group decides to do it voluntarily
and then you measure as accurately as
you can the pattern of physical and
psychological response to those two
conditions what you find is that
independent of the of the weight of the
load
the attitude transforms the response and
so if you confront something difficult
in the spirit of voluntary engagement a
whole different Spirit takes hold of you
and you can measure that we say that's
exactly what I remember Victor Frankel
saying yes he was saying that those in
the in the concentration camp who are
most likely to survive are in fact those
who made meaning out of well so as an
instant said something I think that was
even more profound on that front he said
he left ambiguous the issue of whether
or not you were more likely to survive
if you were a Believer let's say
although he was struck as an atheist by
the composure that true religious
Believers had in the gulag but what he
did say more importantly I would say
even was that if you were a genuine
believer your soul was more likely to
survive and what he meant by that was
many people in the gulag camps became
corrupted and you can think about them
as a microcosm of the world people were
under tremendous stress and one of The
Temptations was to become a trustee and
participate in the system of Oppression
and the camps in Russia could not
possibly have sustained themselves if
the prisoners weren't running them and
that's something to think about with
regards to totalitarianism and and
Soldier Nissan did note and it was
transformative to him that there were
people of genuine religious Faith who
were immobile in their commitment to
ethical action even in the confines of
the cap even when faced with something
like recant or die and maybe not just
you die maybe your family die or maybe
you die in misery and and one of the
things that transformed souljahnitzen
and then the world because his book
transformed the world in large part was
his observation that this genuine
striving to something like Clarity of
speech and a higher Unity could
withstand even the catastrophes of the
good light caps I want to ask a question
just before we enter well I decide here
just to indicate we need to wrap up okay
if I just want to ask one last question
because I'm interested in both both of
you both of you in a sense yeah I said
that you know from from a Muslim
perspective the question that we're
asked to ask is bring the evidence yeah
if I were to bring reasonable evidence
which would satisfy some kind of
probabilistic reasoning that the Prophet
Muhammad
we believe is the final Prophet right
that he was a true Prophet would you be
willing to become a Muslim
I wouldn't
um
I wouldn't
viewed a priority the idea that Muhammad
was a true prophet
but I don't understand what that means
it's like obviously so this is the way
I'm going to look at this
psychologically again you know it's
people are granted Revelations and it's
obviously the case let's speak
empirically that the revelation of
Muhammad United a fractious society and
so it was a uniting revelation now how
to conceptualize but it's not a
universally uniting Revelation at least
not yet or not now because we're not all
United so
why maybe we didn't understand the
Revelation point it's one possibility is
the presupposition what you're saying
that Unity is the ultimate objective
well not exactly you know because then
you have the problem of uniformity that
you you know even the idea of unity
itself I mean is that well we talked
about okay so Unity is a great just to
be clear yeah I believe that Unity is a
great objective yeah but I don't think
it's the old defining one for example
um if there's a if there is an injustice
that is so great that this Unity is more
appropriate than I can imagine
situations where this Unity is probably
better than Unity right I'm sure you can
as well for example like that would be a
false Unity yes exactly so that's what
that's why you wanted to address the
elephant under this yeah yeah but wait
because you can't have a false piece
exactly and we can't incorporate things
we can't yet incorporate yes the reason
I'm bringing this to your attention is
because I feel like it's my duty as a
Muslim especially in the muskrats to to
tell you that
um as Muslims we believe that the
previous dispensations as they were like
Christianity and Judaism they are part
of our faith in a sense not in the sense
of believing the doctrines and all of
that kind of things like we obviously
don't believe in original sin or the
Resurrection the crucifixion all those
kind of things we don't believe in any
of that or the Trinity of course
um but in the sense that we do believe
in Jesus Christ we believe in all of the
Old Testament prophets most of them if
not all of them you know Abraham Moses
Jesus and so on and we believe that each
Prophet was sent was two things the
message which is to Believe In Worship
in one God and some kind of evidence to
indicate their truthfulness
so with for example Moses and Jesus we
know what their miracles are splaying
the scene and we believe that actually
happened historically right we have no
qualms with that we don't have this kind
of materialistic viewpoint on the issue
uh with Muhammad we believe that his
because he was sent to All of humanity
he had to have a an Evidence base that
would satisfy not just the eyes in other
words it wouldn't be just something that
could be witnessed it would be something
that can be interrogated and scrutinized
for all times and places so it would be
an auditory of Revelation in this case
it's the Quran the Quran means a
recitation yeah so the central message
of the Quran is or the idea of
worshiping one God and believing in one
God as we've mentioned
but there are some there is an attempt
in the Quran to challenge like for
example there's something called the
falsification test
or the inimitability test
the Quran says for example that try and
find a contradiction within the Quran
had it been from other than God
found in many contradictions
it's this inevitability challenge is to
produce something as sophisticated as it
in terms of the linguistic composition
as well as the structural component
um this is very interesting because now
even Western academics like Angelica
nuris and others have said that this
this challenge has not been met it's a
German orientalist she's recently said
this
um so this is another thing and then you
have a range of prophecies for example
like if you look at the Deuteronomy
chapter 18 verse 21. it's mentioned in
the Bible that one of the mock Hallmarks
of a true Prophet is that or a false
prophet is that when they talk about the
future that it will be false well the
Quran makes very specific very specific
prophecies about the future for example
in Chapter 30 verse two to four it says
that the Romans had been defeated at
that time there was assassinate Empire
in the Roman Empire and they were in war
with each other and that from three to
nine years that they would defeat the
enemy you see it gave very specific
timelines it gave very specific and this
was a very risky type of uh prediction
because if you got it wrong then it
would endanger and undermine the entire
propheth of the Prophet Muhammad but it
did happen in fact you'll find
Historical things which I'm not even in
the Quran that wrong no the the Persians
sorry that the Romans had been defeated
by the Persians in a battle Yeah uh and
so that's it's mentioned for example The
Chronicles of theophanes which is a
primary source material outside of the
Corazon
um you can find that now it's even
translated into English he he clearly
mentions that
um eight years after this particular
prediction took place it did happen like
that so we have a range of predictions
even that relate to the current day the
prophet said that the the barefooted
Arab because there will be uh competing
for the highest building that's sexually
transmitted diseases would be
proliferated as a result of people
having intercourse outside of marriage
and that this would be something that
would be uh diseases that had never been
there in the past uh the interest rate
interest based economy that we live in
is mentioned by the problem house I said
in the future interests will be
everywhere
whoever does not consume it he will not
be able to evade his dust
so this is another thing so for example
um you've got a range of prophecies
where Islam will spread country by
country where you know this mentions
he's going to go uh
that the Earth has been expanded for me
foreign
and my nation will reach
it's uh points what was projected
understanding East and West if you look
at the Islamic expansion
I mean Barnaby Rogerson yeah who is a
historian he said that the similitude of
the Muslims going Eastward and Westward
and conquering the amount of countries
that they conquered in that early period
which we can read in the book that I'd
given you is like Eskimos taken over
Russia and America
that's what he said
on the point of prophecies even people
like Edward Gibbons they agree that the
Prophecies of the Quran had been met so
I have to ask yeah so I don't I don't I
don't understand the question exactly he
wants to know if you convert to Islam no
I'm saying that that wasn't that's the
question so look I would say to some
degree it's not up to me but my question
was just to remind you the question was
if I gave you evidence that would
satisfy a certain level of probabilistic
no
no because that isn't how I evaluate the
situation how would you evaluate that
well I'm a Muslim enough to have been
invited to your mosque no you always
invite
but I mean this specific I mean this
very specifically you know
um I don't think in some sense
it's a very complicated problem okay
you know when when people meet me on the
street they'll say things like I met a
couple of Orthodox Jews in New York and
they said to me on the street that they
call me Rabbi which was
it's a hell of a thing to hear
you know
and so
and then I have Muslim people who are
listening to my biblical lectures and
more than that they say by the way yeah
yes yes more than that and you know they
say well Peterson doesn't know it yet
but he's really a Muslim and and and
that's very um
that's an honor you know
just like it was an honor to be
approached by these Orthodox Jews and
and that that hasn't only happened once
and I've had lots of correspondence with
people and the same thing has happened
with Orthodox Christians and to some
degree the Catholics and less or so the
Protestants but
and so I don't know exactly what to make
of that we talked about this a little
bit Yeah and let's talk about proof you
know well for me the proof of faith is
the attractiveness of its adherence
not something to think about right well
are you a shining example of the Muslim
faith well how hard do you shine